what i would really do
right i'll just tell you what i would
really do
i would buy
a piece of land probably in malibu right
and i would probably i've always wanted
to kind of design my own house
oh cool you know man and i would do um
i don't know if this is possible but
hear me out i had this fantasy of buying
my own land right and can you do this
can you
dig a mile into the earth a mile yeah
have a mile i'm sure you could but would
you want to live there yeah so i want
the house to be like
when you look at the house right oh it's
like one room tiny little like farmhouse
looking thing you basically just want to
live in that video game
no just listen hear me out right [ __ ]
what's that yeah fallout valley fall out
but yeah the vlog you see a farm house
right
and you walk in right and there's a
walk-in closet
but is it no it's a [ __ ] elevator
right and i live underground that is his
dream no windows no windows right
like yeah literally yeah like that's it
that's right you're describing the game
that yeah
yeah that's the game i was playing i
played that too yeah yeah yeah so that's
essentially the game right it's just
like i live right i'm not the game the
one i just have a pool down there yeah
right yeah a wave pool where i could
surf
oh yeah yeah yeah all kinds of stuff
going on i'd be down there yeah i would
have
aquariums and all kinds of stuff down
there that you know what i would
do with a billion dollars
there's this place and i think it's in
the middle east i don't know if it's um
abu dhabi or dubai where they have it's
kind of similar to that but it's like an
underwater um city
and you can dive there and free dive to
like different levels can you look that
up gayle oh i've seen that [ __ ] it's so
cool you can scuba dive right you could
stick with that you can free dive but
they have different like
rooms with different themes and it just
i mean nothing beats the ocean but
that's i thought that was pretty cool so
i'd probably build one of those just in
my backyard i just imagine bobby you
would be like you'd buy like a jet pack
and then just like zoom around in the
air i would do that too the billion
dollars right i'm gonna spend all that
in the house
i'd have a jet pack and all kinds of
stuff
a water pack i would have a water pack
what's a water pack it makes me zoom
around in the water oh they already have
those they're not expensive they have
these little things in it you just hold
it and it zips you around you can't find
i know really i know you're talking yeah
that's it the world's deepest pool yes
it's in dubai it's an indoor
like deep dive people can watch you do
it there's windows and stuff you see
that babe yeah jeff ross says that no
jeff ross does not have that
yeah jeff ross he doesn't have that kind
of money indoors john frost says this
okay if you go to jeff ross ross's house
that's cool okay
and you go to his bedroom right
the window
to his bedroom
is the bottom of his pool
yeah but it's not the deepest pool i'm
just saying though it's kind of like
that but it's very 80s i think yeah yeah
i think it's cool you know those
restaurants where like you see like the
mermaids like um swimming around you and
stuff yeah yeah he's got a really nice
house
you would do that make like a little
hobbit home oh that'd be cool too and
that's what the inside looks like like
this
what
the hobbit home yeah so i mean it's like
a map but basically
you the front would be i think somewhere
right here yeah it's like a tunnel and
it goes down deep
just layers of home yeah that's what
bobby wants yeah is that good for is
is that bad for you yeah you don't get
vitamin d and it's a whole can you pump
in vitamin d though you could take
vitamin e every day but no no i pump it
in what do you pump it in
these vents
no but if you pump it into the you know
what are the things that sun give you it
gives you vitamin d what else c2
like sunny delight
all right all right so you i'll pump in
vitamin d right how about this could you
have like one of those like
a window right and have it's like a
screen of the sun you could like uv
light maybe you'd be like therapy yeah
i would do all that stuff right to make
it seem but i just don't want to see the
actual sun oh wow you really don't like
the sun do you you love hawaii
the sun there he doesn't go out i don't
want that i don't go during the day like
at night i like it oh
yeah he doesn't he loves going out only
at night
yeah the sun you know what it's it's all
right
you know it's not my best friend but you
know it's all right i don't know it's
not my enemy
you know it's just when i see it i'm
like
maybe i'm used to it you know i'll be
honest with you all my life i've seen
the sun
and just like you guys i have a question
yeah the way
so like when you watch like you don't
get emotional or like feel thankful or
have some sense of like feeling of
gratitude when you see like the sun rise
or the sun go down you're just kind of
like sunset like it doesn't like you're
not in awe
i think i forced myself to be in on with
it because everyone else